[Música]
hola yo soy natalia y les va a hablar de
un tema que está muy de moda
inteligencia emocional pero si es la
inteligencia emocional yo les voy a
explicar que es como yo entenderla y
aplicarla en mi vida
por donde pesar
ya sé cuando yo era pequeña mis papás y
mis abuelos me decían que era muy enojón
y berrinchuda pero como esto no mostrar
puede ser un haber en ciudad sino lo que
quiere es un poco de agua
primer tee papás nunca catalogan a sus
hijos sin conocerlos realmente porque
las etiquetas que nos ponen así eres
súper corajudo eres muy distraída eres
súper floja hacen que en realidad nos
creamos así hice algo que nos acompañe
toda nuestra vida y luego nos será más
difícil descubrir que somos en realidad
y que somos jamás amar y sabas a alegría
en una película de disney nos
demostraron keys sting conmociones miedo
tristeza ira desagrado y alegría en la
que película me refiero verdad
pues déjenme contarles que después de
investigar de hecho son las únicas
emociones que existen y se derivan un
sinfín de sentimientos
segundo tipo no es malo sentir cualquier
cosa lo negativo es que se sentirte
dominica va ser algo que no eres y es
cuando la inteligencia emocional de
giacomo supere a salvarnos
sabe qué es lo que más amamos los niños
de ahora los dispositivos electrónicos
yo tengo un ipod que me hace muy feliz
bueno me hacía
porque hace poco estaba jugando con ese
peluche pancho uno es adorable un
poquito más grande que yo y como no
podía faltar mi iphone 2 y está
acompañando y por descuido de pancho
resbaló de su panza y dejó de funcionar
eso me llevó está en estado de shock
experimenté miedo enojo y tristeza un
enorme y profunda tristeza que me llevó
a estar de luto
tercer tipo papas lo que nos gusta lo
cuidamos pero los accidentes existen en
esos momentos necesitamos comprensión y
no regaños o recomendaciones de cómo
cuidar algo que ya está roto
se ven porque supe que tenía miedo enojo
y tristeza
porque estas emociones se sienten en el
cuerpo me duele la garganta
luego la panza y por último se tumba así
en el pecho pero no me sentí mal por
tenerlas todas las hemos tenido cuando
perdemos algo que queremos cierto a mí
me sirve mucho irme encerrar en el
cuarto porque mientras vivo esas
emociones intensas no me desquito o le
echo la culpa a alguien más porque
imagínense el daño que le podemos hacer
a las personas si no controlamos
nuestras reacciones
a pesar de estar aislada me gusta que
vayan a darme un abrazo y compartir mi
dolor nunca falla
cuando yo era más pequeña muchos años
fue yoga y me enseñaron a respirar
cuando te alteras tu respiración cambia
se acorta y se agita y para volver que
vuelve a su ritmo normal a grabarlo
conmigo cierren los ojos y sientan como
el aire entra y sale de su cuerpo
ahora en los ojos
y en unos segundos como por arte de
magia en la respiración vuelve a su
ritmo normal junto con la claridad
mental cuarto tip aprendan a respirar no
es tan difícil
volviendo lo de mi ipod cuando estuve
más tranquila supe que no tenía que
estar en hoja con pancho porque no tuve
la culpa que existían sólo tienes que el
mundo no se acababa que se aceptaba la
responsabilidad de lo que había pasado
la solución se haría más fácil y que
todo el tiempo hay cosas que están en
mis manos quinto tipo pass déjenos
experimentar y equivocarnos
bueno no todos los días pierdes algo que
quieres tanto cierto pero qué pasa con
las pequeñas cosas que pasan a diario y
que no nos gustan yo tengo un hermano
que se llama bruno donde cree que es
buena y amable pero saben que conmigo no
es así se la pasa ahora están molestando
molestándome o burlándose mí eso antes
me desesperaba y sacaba la peor versión
de mí pero ahora que aprendí a tomar sus
comentarios en una forma de juego y no
con mala intención éstos desaparecieron
ahora nos llevamos bien y pasamos buenos
momentos juntos sexto tipo de incentivo
para entender a las personas buenas
sorpresas se pueden llevar
hay veces que llegó a la escuela y
alguna de mis amigas tiene mala cara la
salud y no me contesta trato de
relajarme y me pongo en su lugar tal vez
tuvo una mala mañana trato de hablar con
ella y si no quiere no insisto le doy su
espacio ya se tranquilizara generalmente
se calman al cabo de un rato platicamos
y todo sigue como si nada pero si yo no
hubiera empatía con ella me hubiera
enojado y el problema si derecho más
grande de lo que ya era
séptimo tip hay sus niños con problemas
de casa tengan la paciencia y no se
tomen nada personal
a mí me sucedía que en época de exámenes
me angustiaba mucho bien ya que mi verbo
y nada muy mal
claro que me va tan mal porque si
estudiaba pero la constante idea de que
mis resultados iban a ser malos y el
sentimiento de temor a las
calificaciones me hacía pasar muy malos
ratos ahora espero lo mejor hago mi
parte y estoy más tranquila
octavo tip recuerden que siempre esperar
lo mejor
ayuda mucho a que el camino por recorrer
sea más feliz
como les comenté en un principio los
niños somos amor y alegría y tratamos de
ser así la mayor parte del tiempo y
queremos verle lado positivo a las cosas
así que por favor papás no nos tienen la
cabeza con información que no podemos
procesar porque lo único que nos causan
son miedos e inseguridad a un mundo que
aún estamos listos para comprender
noveno tipo en uno pueden convertirse en
algo muy diferente si lo vemos desde
nuestros ojos con optimismo conclusión
para mí la inteligencia emocional es
poder controlar tus sentimientos y
emociones con el fin de hacer lo
correcto y reaccionar de una mejor
manera es básico en nuestra vida ahora
ya saben que cuando se despierte o se
les rompe algo valioso para ustedes no
se ponga triste enojado o como sea que
se sientan estas cosas pasan existen
soluciones mientras tengan una buena
actitud
si creen que no pueden poner buena cara
a lo que les pasa piensen en todas las
cosas por las que tienen que dar gracias
nunca falla lista de cosas por las que
tenemos por dar gracias es inmensa y te
puede distraer de cualquier emoción
negativa último tips conozcan se de
seguro se caerán muy bien gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]